when the last hour European judges have
ruled that the rights of more than one
thousand prisoners were breached when
they were banned from voting in
elections between 2009 and 2011 so are
they right shoulda nates be allowed to
vote or did they lose that right when
they were convicted of their crimes
while joining us now to discuss this are
Steve die gravy from prison consultants
which gives advice to inmates also with
this the journalist Jake Wallis Simon's
before we get started there a man that
you can join the debate to you can get
in touch all the usual ways you can
tweet us at Sky News at Jane second sky
including the hashtag sky debate text on
it for 50 on our email news at sky com
let us know what you think or if there
are any points that you want to put to
our guests here and we'll try to read
out some of your comments as we go along
right let's start with that with you
Steve dag where you from prison
consultants these people in prison they
have committed a crime they have
presumably breached somebody else's
human rights why should they be allowed
to vote not a person I think that turn
is my opinion that prisoners should be
allowed to vote for one simple reason
it's in the first is to understand the
function of a prison people are sent to
prison as punishment they are not sent
there to be punished and the purpose of
prison is to rehabilitate people so that
when they are finally released they live
a life that is fulfilling and law
abiding and they pay the taxes etc now
if if by sending people to prison we are
telling them that you we're going to
breach your human rights we're going to
deny you the vote we're gonna we're
going to tell you that your you don't
count anymore then you are you are
denigrating that person far too much and
effectively you are you're kicking a man
while he's down when you what you should
be doing in prison is is building the
man or the woman back up again so that
they are ready to reenter society as a
law-abiding citizen so in my view is
quite simple my view it's part of the
rehabilitation process and this country
has got a terrible reputation as far as
terrible as statistics files
rehabilitation is concerned and
rehabilitation cost this country
somewhere in the region of 13 billion
pounds a year okay so I feel that
anything that can be done to assist
rehabilitation should be looked at okay
well as percentage points to Jake
Simon's at Jake as you saying that
prison is about rehabilitation or it
should be shouldn't it and the prison
should be a punishment in itself we
shouldn't punish people further when
they're there two wrongs don't make a
right essentially well that's right but
i think that the majority the british
public will agree with me when I say
that depriving prisoners of the vote
gives the right message both to
prisoners themselves and the victims who
often forgotten in this debate and the
general public I mean from the point of
view of a prisoner whether you're a
pedophile or a rapist or a murderer or a
fraud stir you have ridden roughshod
over the rule of law over the social
contract and caused immense harm to
innocent people and I think it's only
right that society should then say that
we no longer trust your judgment we do
not want you to contribute towards
having a political influence of our
country or choosing the next government
for the period that you're inside
obviously after your release news page
or debt to society that changes and
thinking about it from the point of view
of the victims i mean if you're a victim
of rape or somebody has killed one of
your family members to then think that
that person is sitting behind bars
casting an election to choose the next
prime minister and the next government i
think we'll leave a very bitter taste
indeed and from the point of view of
wider society i think that giving the
vote to prisoners somehow cheapens the
vote I mean the vote the right to vote
is obviously a right but it's also a
privilege it's something that we should
value and hold dear it's something which
previous generations have fought and in
many cases died for and sharing it with
people who have been guilty of
pedophilia or rape or fraud or whatever
I think cheapens it in the public art
okay what about that point Steve that
voting is seen by many as a privilege a
privilege for those who are in society
these people are paying a debt to
society shouldn't they be excluded from
that well that's a good point and I
understand the sentiment I understand
the sentiment the public is probably
it's probably back in Jake's theory
however it is a right it is it is been
it's been decreed by the European Court
of Human Rights that the prisoners
should be allowed to vote and surely
isn't it hypocritical that when somebody
is sent to prison by by courts for not
upholding the law or holding themselves
above the law that they had that there
then decisions about their prison
sentence are taken which are again above
the law so isn't that somewhat
hypocritical I mean Jake you know how
would you answer that first of all
they've got more points pretty well I
mean I mean the fact is that it isn't a
fundamental human right it's not
mentioned anywhere in the European
Convention on Human Rights specifically
it's not mentioned in the United Nations
Covenant on Civil and digital rights or
anywhere else in in international law
and Britain's parliament has said that
we don't think that it's right for
prisoners to have the vote this ruling
comes from the European Court of Human
Rights which has interpreted article 3
of the European Commission on Human
Rights which says that people have a
right to a free election that doesn't
mention prisoners that's open to
interpretation is something which
Britain doesn't interpret in that way we
don't think our Parliament I said that
we don't think the prisoners should be
given the right to vote the European
Court of Human Rights has disagreed and
is seeking to impose its will on our
country and I think that that's wrong
they should they should butt out and
leave us alone and let sovereign nations
make up their own minds on this issue I
mean if you look all across Europe
there's a range of different policies in
different countries I think about 10 or
15 different countries have a blanket
ban on business voting some don't have a
band but then they get round it by not
releasing prisoners on polling day and
some have a ban on the most serious
prisoners and what this indicates is
that it's a matter about which sovereign
nations disagree and it should be
decided on a sovereign level not imposed
on us by Strasbourg Steve would you
welcome it being decided on a
case-by-case level perhaps the most
serious cases the horrific crimes the
horrific murders but that the people who
are locked up for ironist and
non-payment of council tax perhaps the
people are lesser offenses perhaps on
those crimes with less than a year
sentence should be allowed well I think
you should look at the time left to
serve I mean if somebody is going to be
in prison for the next 20 25 years for
example then I think it
logical way could be argued that that
person may forgo his right to vote but
if someone's doing a short sentence for
a misdemeanor and they are due to be
released say within the time of the next
parliament say with the next year or
five years or whatever then I feel their
voice should be heard and what about
people who are let out on appeal if
somebody if somebody is is is ultimately
found not guilty who wasn't allowed to
vote and they're released on appeal they
can't get their vote retrospectively and
for me it's about rehabilitation it's
simple as that okay Jake I mean it's
already the case that prisoners in
Britain if they've got six months left
serve on their sentence they can vote
prisoners who are on remand can vote and
just to pick up the point about
rehabilitation I mean I had a chat with
you just before in the green room and
you acknowledge that a key moment for
rehabilitation is acknowledging
responsibility for what you've done
there's a point where you have to as a
prisoner stop really against the courts
stop raining it's the unfairness of the
world and take responsibility for the
fact that you have committed this crime
caused harm to innocent people and at
that point you can begin to rebuild your
life and rehabilitate yourself to rejoin
society and I think that if prisoners
are in prison in prison preoccupied with
their rights my right to vote or my
rights to hold elected office or or
whatever it is i think that acts as an
obstacle to taking responsibility for
what you've done and actually works
against the process of rehabilitation
let's just ask you Steve we've asked our
viewers for their views for their
thoughts lots have been coming in to us
coming down on both sides of the
argument really I put to you Mr
Fitzsimmons she emailed and she's
tweeted in do they have the right to
vote why is this even being debated she
refers to mark bridger he is the man
that of course killed four year old
April Jones and Wales he has the right
to vote I don't think so that there is a
great deal of palpable outrage amongst
the general public isn't there that
people who have committed these horrific
crimes do seem to have quite an easy
life in prison honey no you say that it
is about rehabilitation but
is also about punishment it's easy to
focus on the people who have committed
horrific crimes and these people are a
small percentage of the prison
population a large percentage of the
prison population of those who haven't
committed massive crimes we're talking
or heinous crimes and are doing short
sentences and my argument is this is
that the people like Mark Bridger are
probably not going to be released into
society back into society however most
people ninety-nine percent of the prison
population do come back into society and
my view is this is that when somebody
goes into prison that the the
rehabilitation starts the day that they
arrive in prison and part of that is
telling the prisoner look you need to
take you need to take responsibility for
what you've done you need to accept that
you're here you need to engage with us
you need to show us that you are keen to
rehabilitate and I think it sends out
the wrong signal to the prisoner is that
the first thing he gets told when or he
or she gets told when she Rises prison
is that where take we're taking away a
ruling that's been given by the European
Court of Human Rights and they're easier
you're you're you're not allowed to vote
and I come back to my point is that if
you keep kicking somebody one they're
down it becomes very difficult for them
to get back up and it leads on to other
things such as the the ability to get
back into employment the ability to get
a bank account the ability to get
insurance you what you're doing is
you're you're you're never forgiving an
offender and basically if a prisoner
comes out of prison then he should at
some point he should be allowed back
into society and I think if this is a
rolling than they should be given okay
Steve Jake but I mean focusing on
prisoners who are serving the shortest
sentences is equally as deceptive as
focusing on those who are serving the
longest sentences I mean if somebody is
only serving a year the chances that's
going to fall over a general election
anyway are pretty slim and I think from
the public's point of view there is a
lot of concern that sentences as a whole
are too short I I think that conditions
in prison are horrendous I don't want to
detract from that but there is a sense
that there is that too much lenient
leniency around and prisoners doing
short sentences and getting off back
into society without really having
thought about what they've done already
toty what about this project what about
what about the point that it
discriminates disproportionately because
those who are in prison are
disproportionately from often the most
disenfranchised parts of society that
point made by Paul trembath who got in
touch on Twitter he says if anyone needs
representation is the people who
whatever they have done are thought by
some to deserve no rights at all isn't
this a fair point though that those
imprisoned perhaps need the greatest
representation society in the greatest
chance to say how society should change
Jake well III do have some sympathy with
that point of view I mean I understand
that if you're in prison and you're
suffering poor conditions overcrowding
and so forth there will be a feeling
that your voice isn't being heard by
politicians because you can't vote I can
see that but I think we have to return
to this point prisoners need to ask
themselves why are they inside it's not
because society is unfair it's not
because there are from a certain
impoverished sector of society it's
because they'd broken the law and with
every crime there are victims whether
it's a Ponzi scheme or fraud or whether
it's murder or rape or pedophilia
whatever the crime it causes harm to
innocent people and it causes harm to
society and that is why they locked up
for no other reason and prisoners need
to accept the responsibility for the
fact that they have committed that crime
they have as I said ridden roughshod
over the rule of law and over society's
expectations and it's time for them to
stop demanding rights and start to come
to terms with the fact that they've done
that and then accept responsibility and
move on and rejoin society as a
rehabilitated person and then take their
full place be able to vote again and
join us in in a full way okay Jake what
a summary a lot of our viewers who will
be agreeing with you the European Court
of Human Rights doesn't though and Steve
dag worthy doesn't either thank you both
gentlemen very much for joining us